let's take our next call today we will
go to the 701 area code we're taking
calls at 6 17 8 30 47 5701 caller what's
your name where are you calling from and
jump right into your question David uh
this is Paul here from Fargo North
Dakota great question is I'm kind of
curious so much your thoughts are maybe
what some of the audience might think to
about a different kind of approach to
kind of taking on health care we know
that Bernie Sanders no supporting the
Medicare for all and we know that
there's that that bill that's kind of
going to be pushed through right now
pending that a lot of those you know
maybe more corporate Democrats and
Republicans I just don't really see that
going for curious what you thought of a
new approach maybe you know consumers
directly kind of organizing their own
sort of protests maybe kind of outspoken
movements may be against the insurance
companies directly because bad press
sometimes get gets things gets the
conversation changing you know can
create product recalls etc you know some
kind of curious of people I think about
that well listen wendell potter wrote in
his book deadly spin and we've
interviewed him about this about how a
specific insurance decision not to cover
i think it was a young girls I don't
remember if it was a liver transplant I
don't remember the specifics but the bad
press around it made the insurance
company reverse their decision in that
particular case I don't know what you're
thinking of that would make insurance in
other words thich I don't I don't know
what kind of protests could achieve
fundamental change because if you're
protesting the insurance companies the
real solution which is a single-payer
type system would would would cut out
insurance companies altogether so you're
not going to get insurance companies to
say hey we're going to shut down because
people are protesting us so I like the
idea of a sort so-called consumer revolt
against insurance companies that in that
that are making money off of deciding
who gets what treatment but I'm just not
sure what you have in mind that could
actually get changed to happen right ya
know and I fully support single-payer
that's my goal as well
pending that legislation can't get done
in a you know expedient amount of time I
was kind of thinking more so maybe
protesting premium costs deductibles
that that sort of thing more so yeah I
mean the thing is this it's just simple
math right so premiums insurance
companies in many cases have sort of a
certain amount of premiums that they
have to pay back out for reimbursements
for treatment right for procedure is
treatment medications etc so we sort of
know like if you don't have young people
if you don't have a mandate for young
people the average health level of the
people who are insured is going to be
lower and thus premiums are going to go
up a lot of it has to do with math so I
think it's a non-starter to say let's
protest so that premiums will go down a
lot of these things are sort of dictated
by the broader system and math but I
like the way you're thinking about it I
think we need to think about it more and
think what the best path forward would
be right yeah I agree ok yeah and I'm
not all too familiar with the
mathematics behind it so I mean yeah I
may not even be on the rope you know on
the ball on that necessarily either hey
but listen you're thinking and then
you're engaged that's important thank
you so much for the call really
appreciate it definitely an issue that
we're going to take up again